prince used to be up in the
in the vip section with the with the
rose
with his blade crawling a little so bad
mike come in yeah let me tell you how
cold mike was
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hot boxing i'm evan britton and i'm
mike tyson mike you want to bring these
guys in man we got the greats that are
great um listen
no no i'm being sincere i know normally
i'm talking [ __ ] yes behind
um this man right here teddy riley um
ooh he doesn't even know he starts the
career that he doesn't even notice he
started the career
some monster producers he inspired
people
i never really thought about time um i'm
hanging out with somebody and i'm saying
well how do you even do
he said teddy raleigh ronnie jurgen
you know wow can you imagine how
powerful he is they saw you
and you inspired them imagine timberland
all those guys
um devonta it's all those guys [ __ ] you
were the man he started his own
if you read about him he started his own
um era
new jack you know and he made people
that was a that become a part of it
everybody had to become a pocket that
was it bobby brown all these guys um
all these great groups man big bubs and
all those guys man he
yeah he really did it he made us all
proud and stuff
you know yeah he's very always a humble
man
always been humble never tried to be a
big shot it's always humble
and if he did try to be a big child any
time of his life it was so small this
you know he was just such a humble guy
you know
i could tell she's just shaking his hand
introducing myself and said i know who
you are brother
put me right in the soul i appreciate
that
i study i i mean you know i watch the
show so it's like
i watched the show so you know when i
seen the show i knew who you were
and definitely you know this is my
brother here so um
it's such a pleasure to be here you know
thank you i didn't know how
it would turn out you know it was like
you know
you got light up i'm like light up the
smoke
no only if you want not
well actually i do i i vape
you know i have hypothyroidism and it
helped me a lot actually two years ago i
just started
and uh i do it for that for my condition
so i use a
cbg oh it's awesome yeah which is uh
a strand from the hemp plant okay you
have yeah
you usually pull out the cbd yeah i have
cbgs for my
body it's a very nervous problem
tk really came we didn't know you would
come in but listen that's since you're
here then why are you that white brother
what's that why are you the way you are
are you conscious you're very conscious
about your
who you are i notice that you're very
you're just very on top of your [ __ ] of
you
you're expert in you i noticed that for
me at this moment you're just you're an
expert on you
why are you that way i'm this way
because i i really feel like
you can get more by being the temper a
lover at
this level when you're this level you
usually don't get what you want
you know if you may notice that about
yourself because i used to be that way
we all have been like live
we're from new york and we're from l.a
we're from new york
city the hoods you know so being from
here we
we kind of approach it the raw you know
go ratchet
but i realized that that doesn't win
i i've remained a winner being humble
you shoot him with the humble you get
that back
so it's what you give you know um
that's so awesome you know and it's just
so awesome that um
he's that way but his father was just
such the opposite
you know right that's that's what just
trips me out you always been this way
you know and jesus dad my god
but my my real father was okay
treacherous
i would say really yeah he's he's
gene was just something he was amazing
right he was beautiful though
you know he was just his clothing looked
his butt he
yeah but he was um
gene wow this gene is um
what i am now okay you know
conscious of my appearance and
everything that kind of stuff
right right right you know um and as i
did that
i did an investigation on myself why do
i do this
and it's because um i want to hide my
filter
okay from who i was my past and what
i've done so i want to look nice i want
to have no association with what i was
and
that's beautiful a lot of people don't
know like everybody got a little
reputation
right the thing about growth as a man
yeah the thing about growth as a man is
you shouldn't be ashamed of what you was
oh you should only be ashamed if you
stay the same person that's right that
you was
cause life is about growth see so a lot
of people can bring up your old past
but that's just the way the human mind
is but the goal in life is to elevate
every day and when i tell people all the
time
that you opportunity right watch what
i'm about to tell you
opportunity this is where much of people
were watching and listening
to understand what i'm saying
opportunity i was in the philippines
man was sitting talking to me and he
talked about america the people of
america he said you know what y'all
don't have in america
people understand i said what he said
opportunity
he said in here we make a dollar a day
with no government assistance
they get up early in the morning go to
the city and get food out of people's
trash
cans to bring back so families can eat
he said so i took that information and i
and i shared it with the world
i said we have opportunity what's so
crazy people say it's 365 days a year
and i tell people no
it's 365 tries a year
you got 365 tries to get it right and
god wants you to win so badly he'll give
you another [ __ ] 365. who's god
doesn't matter who's god long as you
have faith no no it does matter in a way
look
my this is what you're saying is making
it um
it's taking away what i'm trying to say
oh no i'm sorry so what i'm trying to
say
is yeah we're going down a whole nother
path i don't want to do that that's what
this show is about
yes but the thing is recovery yes and
it's about just knowing who you are and
whatever you believe
as long as you know you've got 365 tries
to accomplish your goal and understand
that it's opportunity all around you
there's no reason for people to be
successful or unsuccessful
just like i see homeless people it
shouldn't be not one and let me speak to
you about the homeless people right i'm
driving i'm everywhere
and i see how they got the architect
under the bridge they got a door to come
out they got carpet
if you can do all that you can get a
[ __ ] job
that's true that's really true if you
could i know some
some got mental illness and some but
what i'm saying ladies and gentlemen
just take that word opportunity and use
it for the rest of your life
and say to yourself it's opportunity all
around
and i guarantee you to change your
mindset on how you move
forward in life
i think our purpose in life for guys
like you and me teddy and us
to be who we are the people who we are
and to um
defeat the world and take care of the
world because we got up thank you for
the opportunity we had the opportunity
to do this
so it should be our um it should be our
opportunity to give them money if
they're begging for money to pay for the
tax that's the taxes for the life that
we have i like that
but i use when i see homeless people you
know what i do
it inspires me more to not to be them
i am that's just i mean that's just my
take that's probably wrong
i wish i had the courage to be though
i'm cool that's deep
yeah yeah i don't have the carriage that
just scares me mike
hey listen um you look at a guy like me
at this stage in my life i'm doing good
got a couple of 100 million dollars
properties and stuff right
[Music]
and i hate myself no i know you don't
look at your [ __ ] you look good
look at your [ __ ] look at do you go
tell me how i feel about myself the more
real
[ __ ] who are you to tell me who are you
period now well this is who i
am right i respect that that's why but
me and you go so way back
but listen you this is just some people
have you don't know what i've seen
that's so true though yeah that's so
true what we all see
yeah that's so true yeah i haven't
walked in your shoes you're absolutely
right
isn't that something i hate myself i
think i'm a piece of [ __ ] but then again
i think i'm beautiful i'm a bad
[ __ ] the baddest [ __ ] on the
planet
and when i think like that that is my
sin that's my shame
my guilt but i'm the baddest man on the
planet
right i'm just so um i hate being who i
am and i'm nothing
being from brownsville i'm nothing so i
invaded i
created this i am my god okay the
baddest man in the planet because in
real life i'm nothing
okay even though i accomplished i'm
nothing but i still keep accomplishing
more and more
right right because i feel like that i
feel like i haven't accomplished
a lot and every day i just feel like i
have something to prove
and i don't know if i dislike myself no
i know what you are [ __ ]
you just don't want to accept it you're
a megalomania with a low self-worth
hmm or what a megalomania you think
you're god but you feel like [ __ ]
no you sure yeah sure yeah
well that's who i am okay i love life i
just love life
i love what all our experiences have
brought us together
when from the days used to pick me up in
the lamborghini with the doors on the
side
he used to take me to madonna's house
hanging with haitian jack
when i mean our journey
goes back since 86
87 like we have so many great memories
we before boys to men not boys and men
uh what's the guys in new york city that
um
from charlotte north carolina enjoyed
the season jody yeah
we was at the club on manchester avenue
listen
um what's the name of that club man
what's the name of it
named that club and then someone is his
son the son that he won the grammy for
man and the name of that club i don't
know but mike didn't tell me who they
were
yeah they weren't singers right and i
talked about them
i got so bad on on stage and they were
mad at you all they wanted to [ __ ]
kill this [ __ ]
crazy i remember that you brought that
up we got crazy stories didn't he
protect me one time
because i had got jumped remember the
time i got jumped man you been so much
[ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ]
listen that's the typical he's a
comedian what will you [ __ ]
i was a little bit everything yeah
people don't know yo
listen to it i don't know what the [ __ ]
you did to eddie murphy [ __ ] well i
didn't do it to eddie all right i stole
charlie murphy's watch yeah i know
something happened
yeah this is
and he always whenever we got together
what i liked about mike
he used to always say don't worry about
that you were we were kids
that's that's what always made me feel
good he said don't worry about cause one
day we're in
we're in um vegas me
you and um
my god from harlem zip zip everyone said
so we're talking now people don't know
me von zip back but they was roommates
yeah he told me you [ __ ] robbed me
[ __ ] but i didn't rob well he told me
that's my
[ __ ]
zip got evicted and the people that own
the house
the thing about see i didn't grow up as
a robber i had you know i got my
reputation but
it's where i'm at today so me him and
zip
is standing out in front of the mgm mike
says come on let's go
so we walking through the mgm
we got security but i'm acting like the
securities for me too cause now i'm
famous so i'm waving at people
using his security guards they see me
with bikes
we walked this take this whole walk we
go down the steps i've never been
through the mgm before
we're going down a step sideways we're
going down more steps sideways
we open the door we walk in the parking
lot we get in the truck
and mike said man i got there's so much
[ __ ] i got to do to smoke this
[ __ ] joint today
[Laughter]
i'm like where the [ __ ] we going it was
like a nine-mile
walk he just did this because he didn't
want people in his business that was
hilarious
that was hilarious listen um hysterical
listen i i can't believe we're still
alive though no we're here man isn't it
what was the gentleman the gentleman
that we used to all hang out uh
listen right i gave kevin money to run
i remember that and listen you know
who's working for us
jeremy fox is working for this [ __ ]
gotta um
what's that pocket [ __ ] remember back in
them squares with a pocket
right right the physical [ __ ]
yes the digi what's that [ __ ] you know
what at the pencil they were pocket
[ __ ] digital
calculator yeah yeah he was such a
[ __ ] square he had the jerry girl
and he was working kevin so he had him
dressed up and [ __ ] jamie
yeah jamie yeah way back yo
no no what i wanted to tell you about
let's talk about robin harris [ __ ] wow
wow
let's talk about robin's hands [ __ ] what
amazing man
how many stars he gave opportunities to
that would have never had an opportunity
in our life and michael williams
yeah mike mike was beautiful too what
people don't
it's good that he brought that up
crenshaw 43rd and crenshaw is what we
call it
43rd it was the mega of all black comedy
you had to go there you had to go there
i saw them all there that's right
i saw them all that's right if you could
joey what name them i saw them all
and every and it wasn't about how it is
today how some comics won't go on
because somebody else did well yeah
don't talk about the heat was in that
one
and not only did they eat listen listen
you want to talk about heat let me just
forget the comedians right
[ __ ] you better not move when robin
harris is talking
you better you stain your seat don't go
to the bathroom
don't move yeah yeah i hope he's not
talking don't put the light on you and
it was good for five years
it was like a school and i i learned so
much that was just amazing it's magic
there yeah it was just magic i'm talking
about
um every comic
sinbad um the weenie says
you had to come now you had to come
through there
and see we there it was dangerous too
yeah yeah
right it wasn't cool it's dangerous
gangsters all the gangsters without
checking out people looking to rob
yeah we had this definitely in the hood
and that was the great thing i had see i
had the streets when i was coming up
see i had the the hustlers the drug
dealers the bootleggers
they all came to see tk and memories
have um zenos
down on la cienega shannon them had that
i mean we had so many after our joints
yes sir
the power emma carlos and charlie used
to go there
listen to me everybody was a live [ __ ]
we partied with rick
back in the day carlos and charlie's a
la reed and babyface
yes prince used to be up in the in the
vip section
with the with the rose with his leg
crosstalk that's a little [ __ ] so bad
mike yeah let me tell you how cold mike
was michael coming with the jumpsuit
with a million dollar bracelet
on his ankle yes no shirt on oh we
listen to me and me teddy all of us
listen to me
this is the days when i don't know you
really like that [ __ ] dude
i i remember everything y'all we we we
had the women
oh god you hear what the [ __ ] i'm
telling you
[ __ ] really listen to uh listen to
everybody watching
everybody watching i had so many veneers
exactly
it was college it was everybody listen
to me we had
such an amazing time we go to the club
and we just look at each other we're
leaving because everybody had
like the baddest chick we we nah that's
it see you later
[ __ ] oh beautiful listen i'm just so
happy that i have a wife now because
can you imagine i couldn't sleep with
him when i had to have [ __ ] six seven
women in my bed
getting me [ __ ] food making calls
food i still do that
you marry teddy no okay now but you know
teddy you know how that [ __ ]
here we go now mike has some gorgeous
women
ain't no gang at all we ain't
[ __ ] cleveland [ __ ]
yeah to me cleveland
cleveland he had a i rolled up on the
one because we we had so many you don't
know who
is who so i rolled up on this girl bad
ass
beautiful is excuse me sister how are
you doing like
she's not met you before so who you meet
me with she said mike
yeah so she scratched her
eyes she did this because the mike can't
give this woman the biggest yeah
yeah somebody's huge
oh huge and we're talking
and i know mike how mike move i said he
ain't gonna be with this [ __ ] a
that's one story then we got another
story now we're in miami
i introduced to this beautiful girl
named diane so mike is a generous guy
mike
gives the girl ten thousand dollars
after a week knowing her
yeah she called tk my baby ten thousand
and they call you you're a pimp [ __ ]
no i'm just a gentleman you know i'm
like i'm like i'm a motivational speaker
so the girl said t.k mike came to jail i
said listen that's my friend
i said how much you bill she said seven
thousand
i said take the seven thousand put three
000 in the card
and send it back to him i said he'll
give you a hundred thousand
that's because people used to take it
from him so what happened whatever
happened to that [ __ ]
used up all the money you ain't calling
no more she thought i had something to
do with it
he don't call me no more i said [ __ ] i
told you to give him
the seventh the [ __ ] three thousand
back
so i'm in new york with this i'm around
some young kid comes up to me and he
goes like this he's
yo mike um
i'm i'm [ __ ] this girl that you used
to be with one of your girls right
and um she said you did you buy that
[ __ ] a condo that she lived that
apartment that she lives in
i said yeah i think i did
i said yeah [ __ ] that i would take that
[ __ ] don't deserve that [ __ ] [ __ ]
hilarious yeah how's your sister huh
jackie
jackie's good jackie's um crazy but
shecky's
yes yes yes i haven't seen jackie in a
long time oh she's gonna be so happy
that you heard she's uh
jack kay she used to call me all the
time
jackie's my big sister yeah it was a
joke jackie's beautiful she's gonna be
so happy to hear you
man oh jackie actually
i i met actually we came to your first
ruddick fight
yeah i came to the first one hung out
with you
second one hung out with you and i lost
thirty thousand dollars you got six
listen listen now we're good listen
this is a gambler's niggling hammond
hammer mc ham
[ __ ] [ __ ] whoa
listen listen he not remember this oh
[ __ ] tell everybody this and we went
upstairs afterwards because we lost all
our money and we went upstairs with the
pimp dude
and we started taking his money oh
remember yeah he went upstairs
he's like yo we can go upstairs and
finish this i was like all right let's
do it because i don't want to bet down
here
all right they taking out money they
took 60 from him and i was like yo
30 thousand dollars that quick that's
just
crazy crazy right man
can you imagine we were young and crazy
and jackie was with us
i think she was with us and everybody we
all just went upstairs and gambled with
him we took his money and
we ain't get it all back listen man you
know i think about my life and i said
this [ __ ] is so [ __ ] crazy
like when i when i do this [ __ ] life
story this [ __ ] some [ __ ] is just gonna
be
i know i'm gonna be embarrassed rather
she's gonna be a lot of sad [ __ ] but
it's gonna be a lot of
funny [ __ ] right [ __ ] my life is from a
joke [ __ ]
listen i think i'm a hard [ __ ] i'm a
[ __ ] joke
and i mean saying [ __ ] listen one of
these [ __ ] i'm
i'm don king listen this story one of
the story check this out
you're going to relate to this i'm sure
so i'm i'm on
don king calls me up and he said michael
oh jackie gets stung she's mediated so
she gets down on the phone and don tells
me i'm with my girlfriend don tells me
hey let's just do this over i'm going
sorry i'm gonna give you this 50 million
for 25 minutes whatever it was i'm going
to squash the lawsuit and everything
and i'm so happy and then he sends his
plane to pick me up i'm so happy and i'm
so [ __ ] i got money i've been broke
for so many years
[ __ ] 50 million also i tell my girl
come with me i'm bragging with my girl
we're going to be
loaded and um i had cocaine so i did the
cocaine right right
everything was beard i did the cocaine
then i said
this is my [ __ ] plan it's the money
he stole from me
whoa [ __ ] oh y'all
yes sir yeah i did that cocaine
oh what like he's doing me a [ __ ]
favor this is my [ __ ] plane
at first i feel like oh i'm gonna be
bald i'm in the jet the [ __ ]
what is the fire series the six whatever
right yeah and i think the new j
and then this [ __ ] plane he
stole my money and but he's playing me
he playing me like a [ __ ] he's sending
my plane to pick me up
and and then my mind started going
and so dawn picked me up right and i'm
[ __ ] thinking i'm mine he's like hey
brother man i love you man we gonna be
rich [ __ ] the white people [ __ ] and me
and you black people together
[Music]
and i'm looking like and he's driving
i'm in the back seat right jackie's in
the front seat with him
and i was thinking about and i just in
the backseat of the rolls-royce
and i know i go like this i'm in the
back seat and i get
and i kicked on and boom and the car
stopped right now
i think jackie hold that [ __ ] i want to
get in the front seat so that jackie
hold this [ __ ] jackie hold jack
you better i'ma [ __ ] kill you hold
that [ __ ] jackie so i'm hurt
i want to get in the front seat like
really do some [ __ ] right so um but
jackie gets scared
and then no mike we could jackie thing
about the money too [ __ ] i lost it
the cocaine made me forget about the
money and everything right
and i'm beating this [ __ ] and jackie
doesn't want to hold it [ __ ] jackie
wants the money i ain't gonna hold you
let you kill the [ __ ] we gotta get some
money
so jackie let him go and i'm back i'm so
mad at jackie
i'm so mad at jackie right yo and so
this is right so we're in the middle of
me my girlfriend
and jackie i got a box with my weed and
i got cocaine in there right
and so we're in the middle and the cars
are coming by we're going to get [ __ ]
hit
the cop come and picks us up and drive
me to my hotel and say
okay chan thanks and that was it i got
the [ __ ] weed of smelling the cocaine
and
i'm like [ __ ] and the copy says have a
good day champ
that's it well you know he picked me up
on 95 and i'm fighting and then
listen don king's assistant came because
he seen donna took off so we did
and so his assistant started running no
he got in the car and took off he took
off
jackie now i'm seeing the hitch out he
didn't hold him right
and so i'm mad at jake so does his
assistant come over
and he thinks that we're there he said
what the [ __ ] happening since he was i
used to
boom knocking him out so yeah oh right
in that street
in the middle of the [ __ ] highway
he's out cold and i'm yes i'm losing it
right and the cop just can't pick me up
and tell me to have a good day champ
it's like that nothing happened he ain't
he ain't trip on the smell of the weed
if you just throw that box you just saw
that [ __ ] eight balls and [ __ ]
in there
oh yes i have a good thing [ __ ] if i
just saw some [ __ ] on the [ __ ]
highway i said hey all your [ __ ]
check your pocket put your hand sit down
the floor normally it's like hey you're
all sit down
and call some back up what the [ __ ]
these [ __ ] doing out here on the
highway
you know what i mean yeah what these
[ __ ] doing on the highway some [ __ ]
on the highway and guard's gonna hit the
that [ __ ] you can't make up that [ __ ]
yeah i remember i was there
uh mid green yeah [ __ ] this crazy night
he's a born again christian now what
what yeah i saw this
look him up can you [ __ ] mitch keems
a born again [ __ ] christian
wow man so how do you feel yeah since we
all together
and you thought that you was broke
what got that what got you close to the
back on track what motivated you to get
back and take your career another
direction because that's a story of a
lifetime
no shame ego a lot of stuff
you know self-hate huh okay something
still huh mm-hmm
it felt more like family though you got
with your wife
it was more of uh i seen your focus
i i need her in my life because i tell
you about my career lock that big hole
in my heart
let me explain to you let me explain to
you about a real man right i'm gonna say
this before we watch that up there
anytime you could sit with a man
and you see how beautiful his wife is
you know most weak [ __ ] are like oh
she did she that that's weak [ __ ] you
know we me and you came up together
and i just love sitting here talking to
you like old times
and how that no matter how beautiful
your wife is no matter what kind of
money you have
real is real right see real it's real
and i hope that the people listening
understand to young men because we're
trying to push this masculinity thing
um um mike this masculinity thing
with [ __ ] being solved and and
being too emotional
about [ __ ] it's so much in your delivery
about being a man but being honest with
yourself
and moving forward staying positive
that's just a phenomenal thing and
and it's so many levels to you so many
levels
it all comes from you have to destroy
yourself
and rebuild yourself and that's what
life is beautiful because you can always
change you can change right now damn
right
it could always change you're right you
know um and what i think um
what i was what i would say is my best
what allowed me to be successful i would
never tell people
because it wouldn't um it wouldn't make
sense right okay
you know but um what makes me successful
is my ego my desire my self
hate and the fact that i want to be up
more than people want me to be down
and listen right but let's just look at
i don't think much i think i'm um
i have a low self-esteem but i just
don't want nobody to [ __ ] with me
and by and by me being who i am that
stuff and that's just so stupid nobody's
gonna [ __ ] me
but that's in my mind i'm scared
somebody's gonna [ __ ] with me
i'm scared somebody's gonna pat my bike
give me your money [ __ ]
look at it right now i'm scared of that
wow
[ __ ] i was traumatized that's some
traumatized [ __ ] i'm getting something
right now my vicious [ __ ] somebody goes
give me your money i'm scared of that
if somebody does that to me i'm gonna
lose it right
absolutely because that's what i was
when people used to
take my money on my shoes because i
always had nice clothes because when i
was robbed
i always dressed up nice yeah and people
would
although the kids were taking my stuff
okay my jewelry and stuff
you know what time is right right right
i'm the young [ __ ] out there looking
good but
all the bigger kids the big guys like 20
and [ __ ] they take my stuff
right right well that's interesting
about how
your your childhood has such
a tremendous effect on you bro listen
damn peep this no this is gonna [ __ ] you
up mm-hmm
i went from a [ __ ] [ __ ] people taking
my stuff to the baddest [ __ ] on the
planet
mm-hmm what is that about yeah that's
awesome yo
no no no what is that about
my fear mm-hmm i'm a coward
i see what you're saying you turned
something that was that into
something positive no it's not [ __ ]
positive the most fearful can be
the most treacherous yeah it could be
the most strongest
because of your fears yeah you know i'm
saying you fear of anything happening to
you so you become
strong and powerful you know especially
if you're trying to
protect your family or you're trying to
take your your circle
you're saying that's what it was about
being from
i say the hood because all hoods to me
are just alike right you have that
fearful in you
and most people do even the straw is
even the most fear
person you fear you don't say it
you have that fear you're going to
protect your circle
you're going to always protect your
circle yeah
the the scariest guy would shoot first
yeah
yeah you're right yeah listen i always
remember this um
when guys i've been in prison when those
big strong
scary guys come to prison when they come
to prison they make sure they're nice
guys
because people are afraid of them they
let people know hey i'm not that kind of
guy
big strong guys and they come to prison
let people know hey i'm cool
right right you know cause people are
afraid of big [ __ ] big [ __ ] might
want to [ __ ] me
right i'll make me this [ __ ] and make
me do [ __ ] mm-hmm i gotta kill that
[ __ ] right he's gonna
humiliate me in front of everybody
well it's amazing because we used to
hang out you know at least i know that
you had that fear somebody forgot to do
to handle it
because i used to love hanging with that
[ __ ]
25th street
but i wasn't the guy mm-hmm that was
just fear i wasn't right it was just
fear
yeah you know it's good to hear that
with you because like i said
we've known each other over 30 33 34
years
all of us at least 30 something but you
know
you have to understand that that state
that we're figuring we don't even
realize that enough we're figuring out
who we are
at that stage true we don't even know
we're figuring out who we are we're
buying the cars is that going to do it
no we got the jury that cause
no we got the women there we got the
famous that could do no i'm still not
happy what's wrong yeah right what is
wrong that's true
so we believe this like shannon briggs
my brother
we believe um we fall in love with our
dicks
yeah and then we look for a
masculinities and a woman
and we keep that makes us masculine so
we keep [ __ ] them and [ __ ] them
and it's just an illusion the more we
[ __ ] the more the more women we have the
more they take from us
the more left the less we are the more
we [ __ ] the less we are yeah
and we're giving them that energy and
they don't deserve it exactly
it's not it's not just the money it's
just it's the energy
but that's why i'm glad about my
daughters when they were born
same here i stopped flying women places
see when my daughters was born i stopped
flying women
to different parts of the world because
i felt like they were taking from my
children
because the female was just a week two
weeks maybe a month
so instead of giving other women
memories i want to make sure i gave my
children those same memories so i'll go
to cabo i'll go to fiji i'll take my
family
yeah i mean i'm that way down too isn't
that weird that
we as people as we get older we become
more i don't know religious but more god
conscious
more universal i tell people because no
disrespect when i say this we almost
know that
it's almost time oh oh [ __ ] it's over
yeah listen yes
know what's interesting i'm glad you
said that sometimes i say
am i dead yet well i don't know if we're
really dead we might be dead now yeah i
think about that right right
am i dead right right but the great
thing about it is and i hope we all get
another 30 50 years out of this game
but um we're healthy we all look healthy
yeah
we we strive every day which is and
we're with some of the lucky ones
do you think that's luck that's your
perception of luck
i'll use that as a as a metaphor but i i
would use that today
as a little look because you got to have
a little luck on your side i think we
have to have a lot of luck
okay i like that dean right compared to
what we're seeing
i'm not i'm not good at nothing a lot of
my stuff is luck
some guys that do punch i thought i
missed the guy and the guy's on the
ground right
it's with the universe it's not your
time to lose you're gonna be gonna
humble you but it's not now
right right we're gonna humble you we're
gonna matter we're gonna give you a
bigger eagle before we go to humble
you're gonna be really big
you know keep on winning come on give me
that i'm gonna give you that but what
i'm gonna give you after that it's gonna
be something
right you have no idea what's getting
ready to happen right and even tomorrow
in all our lives like kobe going
we have no idea what's getting ready to
happen to us it's true
you know yeah
i know it's so interesting we live every
day like we're going to live forever
it's so true you know and whatever we
forget to even um
even though i'm going to get religious
but sometimes we forget to thank god for
the air that we bring in the universe
that's right
but that's what i'd like to see how we
used to hang
to see us now 37 years later and our
perspectives on
that journey see to hear the things that
you're saying
because the i think we all learn from
each other right so now this
part right now i'm taking things like
i'm gonna tell you some [ __ ] that's
gonna
[ __ ] you up right now [ __ ] i keep
looking when they told me you were
coming i was saying
[ __ ] you know that makes me with my ego
maybe
it's my ego gotta be saying [ __ ] this
[ __ ] is just
um deja vu just because i'm i'm
depressed one day and i'm signing all
the grass some [ __ ] and i'm the
president i don't think i should be
i think i'm too big for this [ __ ] right
and he comes and visits me and he looks
at me i said well what am i doing with
my life
so i'm sorry for myself he said [ __ ]
this is just you go to what you said
something
this is what you do until you hit your
goal maybe this is just something that
told you you said something to that
effect
that's just something you're doing right
now to your [ __ ] comes to that effect
right and now i'm here and you're
looking at my hundred million dollar
product yeah it's just [ __ ] scary i
don't know
because we sat down let me tell you a
story i'm going shopping in caesars
and i saw his name on the thing and i
hadn't seen him in a while
so i said excuse me to the gentleman i
said it's my q a said it all
oh you could come back and say no no no
no mike gonna see me
because i'm family so i went shopping
and all that
and when i came back i saw the line i
said you know
you got to know how to belong excuse
excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me
excuse me
and they made me wait for a second i
said yo just tell mike t.k kirkland here
and we came out when while he was
signing autographs all the successful
people were
signing me i'm sitting just like this he
said tk what am i doing
what am i doing t this is i'm signing
[ __ ]
uh um gloves
i'm signing [ __ ] clubs i said no mike
i said nah
this is just a journey whatever i said
but it inspired them
yeah and that's why when they when i
said he's come in at the [ __ ] i want to
tell him that remember how down i was
right there
yeah and i didn't know he was a cc
that's what i love about him got a
little shame too
what the [ __ ] look he's looking at me
i'm in my height spending millions on
this right look at me now i'm fine
i thought that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i
didn't even look at it like that but so
you never know what people thinking and
the thing
to hear like what i like about him is
the brutal honesty right
you got it the brutal honesty like oh my
god like
that [ __ ] is awesome to me yeah like he
he know that he was broke i didn't know
he was broke only he could tell you that
i'm thinking he's just there to do [ __ ]
for the people
but he was yeah i wasn't broke
financially okay
i was broke spiritually hmm i was
spiritually broken okay
i won the book in fact i had money
financially but i'm so glad that i put a
smile
on your face that day cause we laughed
didn't we that day
i got those pictures we laughed somebody
laughed though
oh we i'm talking about yes that was yes
yes we i mean
i'm talking about we genuinely it was
like we i we we didn't want to leave we
just
changed his phone numbers and and i work
out a lot
and craig boogie called me he said mike
wants to know
what you've been doing with you yeah
yeah i did say that
because you know i'm stuck under here
and i felt
you have no idea i felt like a [ __ ]
king mike
yeah asked me yeah what the [ __ ] i'm
doing
you know the [ __ ] have ripples
of [ __ ] and being on the run
it down the highway with his fists like
man i remember all that stuff with us
this is what i know about life life is
in moments
and some moments people are down and
some moments people are up yes
and that was a damn moment for me okay
and you look beautiful and i want it to
look like that
oh that that that i want you know that
really made me feel amazing you know
like i said yeah i'm doing the right
thing and i'm so glad that
we that energy exchange because for me
to see what was going to happen
months down the line for you to say tk
you knew what the [ __ ] was going to
happen
on that same day because we laughed and
his whole energy no it wasn't that
he came it wasn't that it was not i know
what it was
it was like i don't give a [ __ ] you
broken that you might [ __ ] my [ __ ]
that's what that's right
i feel like i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm here with you what's up
yeah yeah you're my man we had those
years together yeah this is about me
that's about
used to come through the neighborhood
with the lambos
on the phone with the big ass [ __ ]
phones we had back in the day our
insecurities make us believe that we're
nothing without that
yes you know that you're calling me t
you ready and then by him hanging with
our friend kev
kev had us all and we had every pager
there was right oh man
wow because when it first came out
listen listen
i used to get so many pages i didn't go
to the [ __ ] training don
grant don king grabbed my [ __ ] page
and put it in the freezer he had
[ __ ] pasted it and he locked the feet
and he put my phone my
pager in the freezer
i get those girls call me i'm leaving
camp i'm coming [ __ ]
yeah you have a sparring partner who
passed away did you know
the guy that's just um box with you all
the time what was his name
alan what was the name come on [ __ ] i
remember the guy you took got his name
yo
he went to the barbershop i went to in
vegas and he used to tell me about all
you guys
i'm training my soul you know i travel
so much and
and over this last year i'll go back to
the barbershop and
i said he had a stroke in that in the
barber shop i know you're talking about
are you talking about crocodile i think
it's crocodile crocodile right yeah
he's the train with me yeah yeah
crocodile he didn't have a stroke he had
a stroke and yeah
and i said wow [ __ ] yeah he was yeah he
died
listen know what about life um
you um like me right now right or you or
you
um we all got here with somebody even
though that we're not they're not here
no more but without them being our life
we wouldn't be here
isn't that weird yep that's true that's
so they're not with us right now but
without them in our life
for what time they were it wouldn't be
right here that's so true
yeah right it's so true yo and for me
that
for me that was gene yeah you know what
i'm saying because
i used to be this kid in the basement
rocking with a band
right and he used to come and get his
car washed with
you remember david hyatt from where i
remember that name
is the guy who who discovered uh r kelly
yeah oh
the original guy he was the hustler yeah
but what about [ __ ] barry hankerson
he's before barry yeah yeah barry came
actually
barry used to manage me and then when uh
we left barry he went and got uh r kelly
okay so before barry
he was the guy actually that was
watching us and gene was watching us
but gene was more aggressive oh yeah yo
i want to sign y'all he was like yo we
never been signing nobody
like yo that's that's we can't get into
music business so
that was my inspiration and that's what
inspired me not only him it was royal
band with cool and the gang as well
used to take him around to the studios
and that's how i met him to me
and all of the major producers which
made me want to be a producer
how did you learn how to do music daddy
i learned through
my ear you know i'm from the project i
just picked up you know my mom bought me
a casio and i just
take that cassio around just play and
ask the band could i play with them they
was like shorty if you don't know how to
play we taking your casio
right yeah that's how it was like yo you
don't know how to play
you're taking we're taking your cats no
not for it
oh [ __ ] just like he said
everything for me it's not luck it's
blessings
right i started in church okay and uh
you know my mom was like you're gonna
get on the piano today
i said i don't know if i want to go he
said you don't get on a piano but you
tell
right you're gonna get a whip so
i got on that that was the push
that was the push to make me want to
play yeah
and be in the music industry and then
after i got busted you know come on
something to have to teach you a lesson
right now what you get busted for drugs
huh drugs
okay what'd you have on you i had a pcp
okay [ __ ] you something to some white
people or something
who's that who do people know tccp
that's mitch green do pc does come on
yeah
but i went from that i graduated and
went up to cocaine and heroin but right
it was something that really taught me a
lesson when i got busted
okay all these amazing crazy stories hey
listen um
when i went to when i got busted and i
went to spa fit
mm-hmm i was in heaven really
i knew i saw my friends i was scared to
death i thought people were gonna hurt
me
rape me beat me up then i went to the
child hauling yo
[ __ ] what's up mike what's up 30 30
the whole everybody knew me the whole
thing then my ego i wish somebody would
say something to you right right
yeah people i ain't seen for [ __ ] if
this is where you've been right
right yeah that'd be bad i was [ __ ]
he says i became um listen
i became um
i became like gene this is my life the
street life all my friends are killers
drug dealers
people that have some issues right you
know me but they love you mm-hmm that's
right
ain't that some [ __ ] this guy's
gonna kill somebody this guy's gonna
do that but he loves you you know and
you love him he takes
it's just a weird world it's just
strange you know
and you have to be a part of it to know
it to understand it
so you remember now you are
up going around harlem alpo
yeah rich porter listen let me tell you
something
rich poor they used to listen i used to
see this little [ __ ] rich port all the
time because he used to like my cars and
stuff like that with my trees always
come around and zap it down and look at
my money and cars and stuff
but i'm looking to look he's just a kid
right and then one day
um one of the kids from david dan comes
up and he says
um richard is dead yeah
and i thought he died from [ __ ] like
got sick or something i didn't know
he's such a kid i didn't no he's no
[ __ ] drunk there he's no kingpin
he's a little baby i don't even look at
him as an equal he's a little child
he's a big drug dealer he used to be
around me all the time he's never say a
word he's looking at me
we went to high school together yeah
he's sitting with the monster [ __ ]
is that right yeah i know apple that's
crazy
and uh alpo i just recently seen he came
to my show
at the apollo i had a big show at the
apollo with keith sweating everybody and
he came to the backstage i was like yo
it's a ghost right right it's like
seeing the ghost but
you know seeing your friend from way
back well now he feels about himself
i don't know you know it's like it's
it's crazy
you know i remember this when uh when
nikki bonds got out and
went to another disguise and you know my
oldest brother used to work with nikki
okay
so just knowing that um
seeing alpo it's like how you know you
never know how a person feels but i just
hope that
he's uh he's protected you know i'm
saying
i don't want to see nothing bad happen
to anyone what did apple do
everything everything okay you know it's
everything things that we
we could say we've done crazy things
back in our days but
he's done a lot of crazy wow okay
listen listen check this is real talk
i'm not really
a fan of him but we're not better than
him okay i understand
no one yeah we're not better than him
he might be better than some of us if
you look at it from that perspective
if you look at his courage and what he
endured and all that stuff right
yeah you know i'm not a fan of it but
yeah he's really
he went through the big boy walk he had
to go to that big boy walk
and the world knows he had to do what he
had to do and he looked at everybody
he's going to judge
what's up in harlem he used to rob the
banks
what was that [ __ ] who you talking about
um
he just passed too he died he's from
queens though
is he from queens you know the black
dark skinned brother lily from my tall
what's his name
you know teddy you know him so well
teddy he's probably
he's part of um boy george in him yeah
he down with that crew yeah he's down
with the boy judging he's
doing stuff with jay-z in the background
he's the doctor what's all the concerts
dark skinned guy black
people all the concerts is it is it is
it um real black
anybody scared of him yeah yeah
yeah he just one word one name one name
he's like
one name that yeah dawgs him black guy
slam guy like three maybe a month ago
you know what's up in new york this is
your team
oh no in october i found that i have a
guy's name
everybody knows this guy yep black guy
he's from queenstown with supreme team
in those guys
exactly i think that's his name no
that's a problem no
not supreme no that's a prank black guy
i forgot foxy bro i've
got one but he passed and
his son passed too he passed first his
son passed away a week later
i know you're talking about wow he used
to put on all the concerts back in the
day
what i liked
i remember we we did a show at the omni
new york
okay and uh we did the show for boy
george
okay all of them were there everything
yeah i always everybody had on the long
like chat and respect chat about getting
my distance right
you know yeah there was a few people
like that though
you know like you love them but you
gotta love them from afar
like black jets my own black chest and
those guys yeah i used to
i liked those guys i always um from a
distance i grew up with a lot of those
guys
went to school with a lot of those guys
and stuff
yeah it's just interesting man
let me tell you mike no no just think
about
that's us why why why they went there we
didn't go that direction
you know i always go and visit lou and
tut and all those guys
in school then i always say um i should
be in here with them
right i mean you remember when i came to
see you yeah
absolutely it was amazing man because i
didn't think i was going to get in
right so what to see him yeah
yeah that's crazy he had he had
everybody coming to see him
what was that like teddy what it was
like i mean
actually that was my first time coming
to a prison i was going to say have you
ever been to a prison before teddy
besides that
performing yeah but listen right not not
english
performing you would think listen this
is why he's so interesting
this is the understanding you would
think this guy's been through l this guy
was protected
yeah oh yeah he probably seen it but he
never got involved with none of that
really
nasty [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you know i'll
tell you why though
it was alpo and rich rich was always
telling me yo
we don't want you on a street show you
need to be on that keyboard you need to
be making that music
so he never wanted me it's almost crazy
because uh
they wanted to do something to gene and
he mentioned them crazy they wanted
and they were trying to you know they
wanted to do something i was like yo
no we ain't doing this that's still my
godfather right right
you know what i'm saying so i i it's not
like i don't have love for him i just
know
you know something was done to me i'm
not that type of person to hate somebody
hey listen right i just like gene
because um something about gene that's
something about me for some reason
and um gina know what the [ __ ] he's
doing the street [ __ ] also and he runs
into
this [ __ ] yeah what the [ __ ] am i gonna
do i can't do i don't know what to do
he's like it's you know he hasn't he
never had the experience before he don't
know right
and we we i've seen that you guys are so
sorry for him
more than hate him and said they're evil
he took my stuff you have to really have
compassion for him he was overwhelmed
that was the reason
actually while we got back together we
actually got back together
and you know i brought him down to
virginia he when he came down to
virginia he used to come every week
so his way he would go to virginia
before he would go to dc
to see his wife okay and uh
one time he went and this is how we
discovered he had dementia
whoa he actually drove to
coming to virginia he stopped in
greenville
when he stopped in greenville he had his
nephew with him
he left his nephew at the convenience
store went to charlotte fell asleep
police knocked on the window he's like
sir you know where you at
he said yeah yeah i'm in greenville he
said no sir can you step out of the car
you you're in charlotte
so he's the type of person that don't
keep
his numbers in the phone and still keep
paper
right and uh he had my name
on his first page him me his wife you
know
and they called me first and said do you
know eugene griffin
i said yeah so what's wrong everything
is okay
it was like well we i think we
discovered something with him is there a
way you can get in touch with
you know someone from the family i said
well i'm from the family
what do you need me to do so uh it's
like well can you get in touch with any
of the other people i said well
there's donna his wife and uh
we you know they got in touch with her
from you know using the phone book
and uh that's where we discovered he has
yeah awesome it's all dimensional
how old was gene nobody never knew his
age
he was just young looking yeah beautiful
you see you know
yeah he was always let me tell you
something he always looked great you
know and
and nobody never knew his age
they couldn't even say
yo he was like it's a street [ __ ] dream
you know i mean that's like
he was he was a flight [ __ ] on the
corner that's my whole life that's my
whole life it's just just being on the
corner of the [ __ ] corner but i'm
flying the [ __ ] other corner
what the [ __ ] is that about me this is
my life especially at a car wash dude
yeah
y'all go to college like you're saying
something i'm in college right yeah and
i saw
what you said it's very powerful yeah
then we had the sheepskin coats
[Applause]
yeah it's something about the [ __ ]
corner
see we're judged by him we could be
influenced by that you understand where
i'm going
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is on the
corner
listen like i'm thinking something
special going to [ __ ] happen
it is going to happen around
no it is something you discovered
yourself
that's information the corner is
information
that's what the court is then if they're
enslaving everything the corners
information
that's how we go to the corner and let
me let me explain something else to you
why do you think the lord stop us from
staying on the corner now
why do you think that i'm listening you
know why because
we can't stand up we can't get
information then we're confused that's
right
and then when we confuse we make
mistakes right then when we make sticks
we go in front of those people
and then they do whatever they want to
us that's right so they keep us off the
corner before we don't get information i
know it sounds so primitive but isn't
that something
that's so much power to corner and you
have to understand the power because
they don't want you in the corner no
matter the lord the lord came we can't
be on the corner
that for some reason that as a kid that
meant i
see this keep this too right nobody [ __ ]
with them [ __ ] on the corner either
that's right you showed them respect
that's right anything out of respect is
a fighter a shot or something
right no disrespect for them [ __ ] on
the corner right that's right
they had the baddest [ __ ] yeah and
they didn't do nothing but stay on the
corner
that's it it sounds crazy and listen you
might see them go away and they change
their clothes and they can
come back but they're not selling drugs
or nothing right
we're on the corner and you can go to
college
i'm about to get you now you go to
college i go to college come back some
same [ __ ] it's still on the
court four years later
looking good and made the corner look
good yeah we would be on tour
we'd be on tour we came home on the bus
and they were right there
late at night right you still see this
i have to say this though you know um
most of those people on the corner
were like my high school buddies and and
uh
people who have turned like i used to be
in bands with like
the guys who you know later on stuff was
watching my cars
and that was the most hurtful like
seeing like my old guitar player or
somebody and i'm like no
i don't even want you to watch the car
but here's you know some money
you know i just can't see like a guy
that i'm on stage with like i'm playing
high school band and he's on that corner
hey teddy listen right um wow you said
that um you know when i first made money
i used to come back to brownsville and i
used to give all my money to my friends
mm-hmm i did too for them to start the
[ __ ] crack
empire stop it no i used to do it for
them to stop
yeah they started a crack empire with
the money i gave them wow
you know well you have a lot mike yeah
that's why i gave a lot yeah you get a
lot
you sure did listen um i just learned
that from a kid being in the street um
i used to hang out with kids my age
right we used to rob and still and they
just always when they get the money they
take the big part of the money and they
give you
you know yeah but then i started
hustling with some older guys
and they gave me half yeah i said whoa
i'm gonna stick with these guys
and that's why i learned if you there
you're down
i was explaining to um shannon biggs i
was with somebody i had already robbed
somebody so i had a pocket full of money
and clothes but my phone was with
somebody and he was robbing somebody
like he's like i mean you're chilling
and you're robbing him right now but i'm
just waiting for you to finish robbing
him
and we gonna do whatever we're gonna do
right so um
he offered me my last night [ __ ] i want
the [ __ ] money i got [ __ ] money
right
and later on right i didn't even notice
the guy i know he was robbing somebody
taking i know he was checking somebody
right
and i was there but later on
that guy came back with some friends
they almost killed me well wow
so i learned from grounds as well and
from brownsville
if you're there you're down you're down
yeah if you're in if you're not trying
to stop him from robbing me or hurting
me
if you're not trying to stop him you're
down i don't get to take the money
enough you're not trying to help me
you're not trying to tell him hey chill
he's a good guy you're down when i come
back i'm gonna kill you all right and
they almost killed me so i re that's
what i learned
um if you're there you're down so i
remember if i do something
and somebody's i always give them money
speaking of being down man that's what
happened to us
you know we used to be at the rooftop
rooftop roller skating rink and uh
that was the spot to go but it was also
the spot when
when a street dude was looking for a
street dude or looking for somebody
yeah crossfire like a lot of my good
friends had got killed in front of the
rooftop
wow um it's owned by my my uncle uncle
willie
my uncle woody willie burgers yeah so i
remember willie
something happened with my one of our
guys gusto
who owned the rooftop you know he was uh
he was in the street gang you know we
all from the streets but he was in
street game heavy
and you know that's saying once you win
you can't quit
so they basically came back to uh
extort him but we were all in the studio
and they had us all on the ground with
guns to our heads and everything and um
you know when you see your life before
you yeah you know what i'm saying it's
because you were down you were part of
it right and
we were there we were making records we
had just finished
doing a record with cool modi he left
the studio
and those cats came in with guns
everything they had us all on the ground
and we thought we were going to die
because that's the first thing they said
man
we don't get the money out of this cat
right here all y'all gone
damn so when that happened you know it
really woke us up you know it's just
signs of waking up you know and being a
part of something
you know it doesn't pay you know what
i'm saying
especially just being there yes yes yeah
because you never know
yeah so guilty by association
mm-hmm i'm always in a barber shop with
him in brooklyn
and i was in the barbershop and there
was a crackhead in there right and he
said mike ma'am
buy me a haircut give me a hand i said
listen if you let me cut your hair i'll
buy you a haircut so i'm cutting his
hair that's it
and i'm telling you i said what do i do
how do i start right so i'm saying how
did this
start i wanted to cut it i'm an [ __ ]
right because i got money
if you let me cut your hair i paid for
your haircut and he was like i was
trying to cut his hair
and next thing i know the ball but the
owner grabbed me and get him stole me on
the floor what's the [ __ ] thing that
might hear about the lightest
and they were just blasting in there and
um
i didn't know what was going i thought
they were coming to stick me up or
something right
and then um i realized he was he must
have fight
four or five shot boom pump pop power
pump shotgun
and um i thought he was coming for me
he was coming from this guy that stuck
him up with some stick-up kids in there
wow and they stuck him up and killed
some people they came for them but i
thought he was coming for me
you know man
the moral of that is god knows
yes he knows who he wants
and who you know i'm saying it's like he
have a plan listen i never
say um this is what i don't do teddy
right i never say i'm gonna avoid this
this is gonna know listen it's gonna
happen
yeah you just gotta do what you do and
and know that god
knows your heart he knows where you're
supposed to be so he's going
it's a time thing you know yeah i've
been blessed that way too
it's a real time thing man and we've
been
close to the ninth hour of something
we've been close to almost getting when
you hear when you hear these stories
and like i said over 30 something years
and
you know i read about you or see you
somewhere
i'm i'm on facebook and they showing all
mics
fighting seeing him and swinging and
knocking people out the ring
and the phenomenal uppercuts like used
to hit him
or you see him somewhere out of the
country teaching people how to fight you
know he's
you know like that guy he do his hand
like that and then
just like i watch you almost every day
you know
social media they playing them every day
i had left it it's like four in the
morning after i worked out and stuff
and i took some mushrooms and then i'm
used to going to youtube and then i saw
i said what the [ __ ] and um and it's my
ego too cause these [ __ ] think
about me all the time
right you know so i got this thing the
technique of mike type the guy that [ __ ]
some of this guy do you
practice me studying me her whole life
and every move i make they know me
better than i know myself mm-hmm
and i'm looking at myself and i'm always
saying myself [ __ ]
[ __ ] cub will you stop looking at
yourself and stop
you know stop thinking about yourself
right you know you stop
[ __ ] thinking about it and but it's
hard because
you're the only thing that you know
right right right
about yourself yeah yeah the only thing
that you know and i by saying myself
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you ain't who you think
you're like because it gets quicker
they're almost thinking i'm not gone
[ __ ] i'm immortal this and that
and then cause i could see myself saying
that you're feeling but then i go
outside and then people um
affirm it yes but what the the thing
that i watch and then i when i watch you
when i watch you all with the humbleness
i was so
deep down i wish i could be that way i
always play the role like i'm humbled
but deep down i don't got to humble
born in my body but you do yeah you do
right
you do you just don't understand like
i see your your your your interviews
there's your humble until somebody piss
you off like i seen your piss off
moments like you just like yo
yeah you're a gentleman
yeah somebody crossed that line he's
brought up the rape situation
yeah and he was black he said he's a
piece of [ __ ] yeah he is he's a piece of
[ __ ]
yeah yeah get you to ask that question
but listen check it out right
imagine if i would have said well yes
this is true brother but i'm i'm above
that now
i shouldn't have showed him my feelings
i let him know my feelings
and i think that yeah that's not my
feeling a feeling should be our feeling
that's why it's our feeling
nobody should know our feelings right
we're in the it's two worlds
it's the outer world in the entire world
yeah and we can't let the outer world
upset the enemy in the world we watch it
and we watch it on play and sometimes it
gets close to us
but we can't let it disturb this and
that's the game i'm playing now i never
know how to play the game of life
you know that's just winging it that's
the one thing that
mostly takes your energy i got a little
bit of an understanding
that's good that's amazing because i
mean that i'm telling you that's where
your energy goes let's play the game
your energy goes to be important you
have to forget your importance
isn't that something in order to be
great you have to forget your greatness
right you have to give it up ain't that
some [ __ ] though
in order to be great you're already
great but i wanted to be great you got
together
yeah you got to act like you you still
trying to be believe it or not when i'm
out
and i'm in vip and they bring in the
bottles i don't really drink
i would be the other person servant
yo can i get you okay poor people drinks
exactly what you're saying i pour people
drinks and sit down
i'm not acting like give me this move
that get that i don't do that
i make sure everybody else feels
important
and i want to make you feel incredible
because i already know who i am
but but that goes back to what you're
saying you have to transfer that energy
yeah and believe it or not
it can create a lot of peace too and
really taking people wrong and being
disrespectful
you know when i was talking to shannon
this shannon he's a very emotional guy
but he didn't understand this
nobody how come the poorest countries in
the world are the happiest people
yeah they're fighting a while now why is
that
do you know that secret i found that
secret out i want to hear it
you know why um they don't expect
anything
exactly they've never seen what we had
listen
hey you see a guy like me that's trying
to wish i was like ted humble and stuff
what would i do if somebody didn't nudge
him say hi to me imagine my ego what if
i go outside and somebody didn't notice
me
how shallow i am i was at my mother's
grave wow listen this is deep
i was at my mother's grave when i was 16
at the time but i was fighting i won
national titles and stuff
and i was what the [ __ ] i was telling my
mother i'm going to be the greatest
tyson [ __ ] when they mentioned tyson
they're going to be mentioning me and
cecily tyson's not going to be nothing
i'm going to be the greatest tyson ever
lived
and i'm telling this to my mother and i
say i felt that way because i'm such a
i'm so [ __ ] i'm nothing i come from
nothing so i used to want to be
something so bad
i've been humble my whole life i don't
want to be humble because people walked
over me
abused me did anything that a human
being could be done through and just
and i've been coming from that guy to
become this and it's just it's a
psychological [ __ ] traumatic [ __ ]
how did that happen
how did i become scarier than i'm this
guy that people are scared of
right isn't that weird yeah and that
comes from me being afraid i'm afraid
people are afraid of me because i'm
afraid of me
you know when you started boxing how did
you know though
you were talented like what got you to
go
boxing you know what i mean everybody
got them one thing
really i saw muhammad ali and then um
that just saw him personally and that he
that's how much power i
saw him he was so far away from me but i
just saw him and he inspired me and then
from then
i got shipped upstate new york and i get
shipped upstate new york and this
[ __ ] guy used to be a pro boxer he
starts teaching me isn't that weird
wow he started teaching me how to box
wow
and so how did you meet gus he
introduced me to cuffs because he didn't
box his wife's name in the box because i
think he had a black broken nose so
he said i'ma take you somewhere and um
he's gonna take you to another level
and then i watched you watch me box one
day and he said provided no
incidents no problems this is the
youngest heavyweight champion ever i was
13. then
he planted my life up for me and
everything man it's all white italian
guy here set my life for me
and you know back when i'm young you
know we used to always rob white people
and stuff
i had no idea white peoples are savages
oh yes
no disrespect i had no idea when i met
cuss i never know i did look at me i'm a
monster
look what he done to me i don't care
about people feeling i'm emotionless
he told me i was [ __ ] better than
people
why didn't he tell me that you know
everybody's good and why he shouldn't
have told me why did he tell me i was
better than people i'm superior
why does that stick with me why didn't i
say why didn't i right now say hey
you know that's wrong mike that's not
right you're not superior to people
i'd say that all someone deep down in my
heart i say i'm better than these [ __ ]
that's because i feel so little i've
come from [ __ ]
i gotta be better than somebody yeah
mm-hmm that's what you're striving yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i said i can hate you guys man
when i sit back and just know how long
we've known each other know that you've
gone through that
because like i said you you never know
what a person's journey is
listen really sit down in the 80s right
when everybody thought you were [ __ ] you
keep away from you and sugar they think
you might still
listen i understood that i was that
[ __ ] you always showed me love yeah
[ __ ] no
i'm the [ __ ] that everybody say keep
away from the [ __ ] but steal your [ __ ]
i've been that [ __ ] that people whisper
about my whole life and he always
treated when i was going through my
thing
got me by an arm like right by my neck
and just like yo look i don't want to be
gone yup
just and i understood that especially
now here you know because he had
been down the same path of people
talking about you
and even when people you talked to
because they knew he was tight
they just tried to diss me to him he's
like man [ __ ] y'all that's t
to the [ __ ] k you know i
understand people i didn't understand
people back no i did but i know this
when i talk about somebody i'm talking
about myself
when i say that's a bitch-ass [ __ ] i'm
talking about myself when i say don't
trust him i'm talking about myself
i'm untrustworthy i like this so you see
yourself and somebody else
so you're projecting that because i know
no it's not that i see myself
it's that um anything i say to somebody
is the reflection of me
even when i say he's beautiful that's a
reflection of me right
that's the beauty i feel sometimes about
myself wow
i like that that's deep it's funny
because that's true
it is most people who say something
about somebody
have always either experienced it yeah
or they are that how would you know that
how you know to say that if he wasn't
that well let's give you an example
you know we used to say we used to blame
a girl for being with somebody
then we didn't really see it yo yeah but
what the [ __ ] i
say to myself right because i look at
myself i look i look at myself as a
loser
and i failed yeah i know i know i know
teddy
i know teddy but um that's that's weird
right
but why do i why am i a loser but i just
keep succeeding
i'm a [ __ ] sucker for [ __ ] success
i just want to
thrive and win and win and i want to
[ __ ]
in a weird way i want to show off mm-hmm
right
you know i just never want to say to
them if i want to show off why we're on
the air
you thought i was dead you thought i was
dead and i came back y'all brothers
man i'm so happy man we got to see each
other we
got to see each other we got hooked up
in vegas oh yeah
it's so crazy we all in vegas too we all
look i love this stroke so much
and listen everybody follow me at tk
underscore kirkland
uh what about my podcast on the tk
kirkin podcast shout out to mike
surfman the stair uh frenchie and it's
always good seeing the great great great
great teddy rob
shout outs to all my family in new york
north carolina and
vegas california but my uh my instagram
is teddy raleigh number one
teddy rally in one word and the number
one at the end
and uh look forward to the tour we got
the tour coming up the cruises and all
of that stuff
i took off for three months now i'm
about to go back to work we
yeah right you guys look good though
right you guys look good teddy this
trench coat's off the chain
ah thank you thank you hell yeah so mike
i'm gonna call you for the tickets
hey hit him up eat him up bro
i don't want to do yeah you could be
disappointed
hey come on thanks for watching this
episode of hot boxing
until next time i'm evan britton i'm
mike tyson we out
thank you let's get another good picture
guys
oh man this is a yogurt i need a joint
[Music]
now
[Music]